ONE THAT MANY MUNICIPALITIES,
CITIES AND STATES ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO DO.
ON THAT I WANT TO GET THE READ
ON 2020 PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
TULSI GABBARD.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
>> THANKS, CHARLES.
>> Charles: THE NEWS IS COMING
QUICKLY FROM ALL AREAS.
FIRST OF ALL, BILL DE BLASIO
MADE SOME COMMENTS ABOUT RUNNING
LOW ON FOOD.
FAMILIES NEEDING TO SURVIVE AND
PINPOINT IT BACK TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SAYING THAT’S WHERE
IT HAS TO COME FROM.
THAT’S THE MOST IMPORTANT AREA
AND HE MUST MOVE IMMEDIATELY.
I THINK EVERYONE AGREES ON THAT
AND STILL, IT FEELS LIKE THERE
IS A LOT OF STALLING THERE A LOT
OF THE OLD POLITICAL
SHENANIGANS.
>> THIS CONTINUES TO BE A
PROBLEM, UNFORTUNATELY WHERE
PARTISANSHIP IS GETTING IN THE
WAY OF JUST DELIVERING WHAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED RIGHT NOW
ESPECIALLY AS OUR COUNTRY FACES
THIS CRISIS, NOW IS NOT THE TIME
FOR POLITICS, NOW IS THE TIME
FOR LEADERS TO STEP UP, STAND
TOGETHER WE WILL ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER AND TO PUT THE HEALTH
AND WELL-BEING OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ABOVE ALL ELSE IT’S A
LITTLE BIT ENCOURAGING EXPECTING
WE WOULD HAVE VOTES AT 10:00
THIS MORNING ON A DIRECT AID
PACKAGE, DIRECTED TOWARDS
WORKING PEOPLE, EVERY DAY
AMERICANS ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
BUT THERE WAS CONCERN COMING
FROM REPUBLICANS IT WAS NOT
CRAFTED IN THE BIPARTISAN WAY SO
THAT VOTE NEVER HAPPENED AND
LITERALLY BOTH SIDES ARE COMING
TOGETHER, I THINK THEY ARE
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
ON MAKING SURE THAT WHAT WE
PASSED IN CONGRESS IS SOMETHING
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS WORKED
ON AND GET ON THE PRESIDENT’S
DESK AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
>> Charles: THAT’S THE MOST
IMPORTANT POINTED.
I DID SEE WITH MNUCHIN AND
PELOSI HAD SEVERAL CONVERSATIONS
TODAY.
THE IDEA OF THE SAME USUAL BIG
WISH LIST FROM ONE SIDE AND A
BIG WISH LIST FROM THE OTHER AND
ALL THIS WRANGLING, THERE IS NO
TIME FOR THAT.
>> THERE ISN’T.
>> Charles: WIND MILL IS
CLOSING.
THERE SEEMS TO BE LOW HANGING
FRUIT AND WHO WE WANT TO HELP.
EVERYONE WOULD AGREE PAID SICK
LEAVE, FOLKS OUT THERE IN THE
GIG ECONOMY.
PEOPLE OUT THERE WITHOUT HEALTH
INSURANCE.
SOME PRETTY SIMPLE STUFF.
BUT WHAT ABOUT SOMETHING BOLDER
AND BIGGER THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS TALKING ABOUT, THE PAYROLL
TAX CUT.
THIS WAS SOMETHING DEMOCRATS
REALLY SEEMED TO EMBRACE WHEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS IN OFFICE
IT’S SOMETHING THAT HELPS SMALL
BUSINESS EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEE
HE IS AND IT’S HUGE, IT’S BIG,
IT WOULD BE IMPACTFUL.
>>
>> I THINK OVERALL WHEN WE LOOK
ABOUT -- LOOK AT THE STRUGGLES
THAT SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
ESPECIALLY HAVE AND JUST TRYING
TO KEEP THEIR DOORS OPEN AND
KEEP PEOPLE EMPLOYED, I THINK
THAT’S A VERY GOOD DEBATE THAT
WE NEED TO HAVE AND THERE IS A
LOT OF VALUE IN THAT I THINK
WHERE I’M LOOKING IS THIS
IMMEDIATE SHORT-TERM IMPACT AND
THAT’S WHERE I DIFFER A LITTLE
BIT.
I DON’T THINK THIS PAYROLL TAX
CREDIT WILL DO ENOUGH TO HELP
THOSE, FOR EXAMPLE, WHO MAKE
LESS THAN $25,000 A YEAR.
THEY WON’T SEE MUCH OF A HELP
COMING FROM THAT.
AS YOU MENTIONED, THOSE ARE ARE
UBER DRIVERS, THAT’S WHERE THEY
GET THEIR INCOME ON OR WORKING
ON GIG ECONOMY, FREELANCERS,
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WON’T GET
ASSISTANCE FROM THAT PAYROLL TAX
CREDIT.
WHAT I’M PROPOSING IS AN
IMMEDIATE EMERGENCY TEMPORARY
UNIVERSAL BASIC PAYMENT THAT
GOES DIRECTLY TO EVERY ADULT
AMERICAN IN THIS COUNTRY TO HELP
THEM IN THIS DIRE SITUATION
WHERE MOST AMERICANS IN THIS
COUNTRY, THEY ARE WORKING
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK, STRUGGLING
JUST TO GET BY AND DON’T EVEN
HAVE A BUFFER TO THINK ABOUT HOW
DO YOU BUY TWO WEEKS OF FOOD
SUPPLIES FOR YOUR FAMILY AND THE
OTHER CONSIDERATIONS.
>> Charles: LESS THAN 30 SECONDS
BECAUSE OF ALL THE BREAKING
NEWS.
I APPRECIATE YOU STAYING.
NOT MEANS TESTED.
EVERYONE WOULD GET A CHECK.
HOW MUCH WOULD THAT CHECK BE?
>> I’M PROPOSING $1,000.
I THINK THAT CAN BE NEGOTIATED.
AGAIN, THIS IS A TIME OF CRISIS.
WE HAVE BEEN SPENDING $4 BILLION
A MONTH IN AFGHANISTAN WITH A
LOT OF PEOPLE WONDERING WHAT IS
THIS FOR?
HOW IS THIS HELPING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE?
WE NEED TO PUT THE WELL BEING OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE FIRST RIGHT
NOW AND INVEST IN THEM.
>> Charles: THE IDEA THAT THIS
HAS TO BE BIG WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
IN JAPAN GONE TWICE WITH
STIMULUS, EMILY WORKING ON THEIR
THIRD PACKAGE.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PUBLIC IS
GIVING YOU LICENSE TO GO HUGE,
GO AS BIG AS POSSIBLE.
FIRST TIME SO YOU ARE NOT
CHASING THE EPIDEMIC.
IS THAT POSSIBLE?
>> IT IS POSSIBLE, WE HAVE TO
MAKE IT HAPPEN.
I WANT TO MAKE ONE NOTE THE
THING THAT IS HAS NOT YET BEEN D
THAT WE HAVE SEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
COUNTRIES LIKE SOUTH KOREA IS
MASK TESTING, FREE TESTING, NOT
RED TAPE TO GO THROUGH.
WE HAVE GOT TO GET PEOPLE
TESTED.
>> Charles: WE HAVE YOU DOWN FOR